I'd really like to welcome our
first keynote speakers, Mine
Çetinkaya-Rundel and Julia
Lowndes, who are going
to be talking about Quarto.
And there there are literally
like no two better people
suited to give this talk.
Mine is my
colleague at RStudio.
She's also my co-author
of R for Data Science.
She is the professor
of the practice at Duke
and just a fantastic educator.
And I deeply appreciate
her empathy with new R users.
Also, whenever a correctly type
Mine's full name, including
the little dangly cedilla
on the ç,
I give myself a self high five.
Julia Lowndes is a PhD
in marine biology and squids.
She also started OpenScapes
in 2018, supported by Mozilla.
Julia is like
one of the people
I just love to hang
out with at RStudio conf
and whenever I see her
because she is just
so passionate about educating
people about the power of R
and whenever I get
to hang out with her,
I just feel rejuvenated
and excited about the work
that I do.
Unfortunately, Julia
and Mine will not
be taking answering
questions today,
but if you do ask questions on
the Slido, they will read them
and they will pass
them on to the Quarto team.
But they will not be
taking questions today.
So please join me in
welcoming Julia and Mine.
Thanks so much, Hadley, and
Thanks so much to all of you.
We are so excited to be here.
Mine and I have been using
Quarto for over a year now.
Mine has been teaching with
it and has been contributing
to the development of it,
and my teams with Openscapes
were the first external
testers of Quarto.
And as we've used it
over the past year,
we have grown to love
it so much and we
are excited to
welcome you to Quarto.
But also we know
you have questions.
We did too.
What is Quarto?
Why is Quarto? And how
does it interoperate
with R Markdown and your
other existing workflows?
Well, Quarto unifies and
extends the R Markdown ecosystem.
It unifies it for
people who love
R Markdown so that
little points of friction
are reduced as you make
websites and books and slides.
All of those will now
have a common approach
and it extends it for
people who do not yet know
R Markdown
as a friendly way
to work reproducibly
and publish documents
that combine text and code
and output in the same place.
So Quarto is a new open-source,
scientific
and technical publishing system.
And the goal is to
make the process
of creating and collaborating
dramatically better.
So it handles inputs in
multiple languages and outputs
in multiple formats, all
going through the same Quarto
machinery.
So in our talk today, we'll
introduce you to Quarto
through stories and demos.
First, Mine will focus on how
Quarto unifies the R Markdown
ecosystem through stories
of sharing and teaching.
And then I'll focus on how Quarto
extends the R Markdown ecosystem
through collaborating
and reimagining.
So we are so excited
to get started.
So let's kick it off
with you Mine to talk
about sharing with Quarto.
Thanks Julia.
I'm so excited to
have the opportunity
to talk to you
about Quarto, which
I've been living and
breathing over the last year.
So I work at the intersection
of education, research
and development.
The word educator
might make you think
that I am in front of crowds
like this, maybe a bit smaller,
24/7 lecturing at them.
But actually I spend a lot of
my time in front of my computer
creating and authoring
artifacts that I
share with the world for
the purpose of teaching.
And everything
I create, I share openly
with an open license that allows
for use, reuse and adaptation.
I often think web-first
for wider reach,
but I also still
live in the confines
of academia and traditional
publishing, which
means that I still have
to make a lot of PDFs.
Therefore, an
authoring system that
allows me to achieve multiple
outputs from the same inputs,
the same source code that
brings code and prose together
is not only essential for me,
but it's actually, basically
what I need to carry
on my existence.
And for the last decade
that has been
R Markdown for me.
In fact, I remember very
vividly when JJ and Yihui
gave a talk at UseR 2012.
The first UseR I
attended in Nashville.
So I'll kind of go
back to that time when
I attended that
conference, I don't
think I would have identified
myself as an R person.
In fact, I'm pretty sure
we went to that conference
because we were going
to Bonnaroo already
and it was there and
I thought, why not?
This was the summer of my
first year of teaching at Duke.
I was very dedicated
to open science.
I had already been working
on an open source textbook,
but this idea of wider
reach and open science,
but also doing computing,
I had not really
put the pieces together.
And one of the reasons why I had
not put those pieces together
is that I didn't
have a good workflow
to bring them together.
If you know me, you know that I'm
a prolific sharer and I
like things to look pretty as
well, not just be functional.
And pretty.
And I really did not
have a good workflow
for being able to achieve that.
But I started listening
to this keynote on knitr,
and it must have been no
more than 3 slides into it
that I just actually
pulled out my laptop
and started converting my
teaching materials to use it.
Because this idea that I
can bring narrative and then
code together and have it just
be like syntax highlighted
and look organized and be ready
to be published on the web
was just such a dream
come true for me.
And by the end of
that keynote, I
was already brainstorming
ways of not just me
using it, but thinking
about how can I teach this
to my intro students?
So I am going to call
this keynote a success.
if some of you have
already tuned me out,
taken out your laptops
and have gone to quarto.org
to start playing with it.
But I do hope that you will
continue to listen with one ear
and taking these beautiful
illustrations by Alison Horst.
And for those of
you who want to have
a more laid back morning,
you can go to this link:
mine.quarto.pub/
hello-quarto
Sit back and I will
advance the slides for you.
So Julia mentioned that
about unifying the R Markdown
ecosystem.
So let's dig into that
a little bit more.
Here are some of
the packages
from the R Markdown
ecosystem that you've
come to love and rely
on over the years.
Each package addresses
a different need
and solves a different problem.
You might be creating
websites or writing blogs
with blogdown or distill
writing books with bookdown,
writing journal
articles with articles
package. Quarto unifies
the functionality
of these packages on
the technical side,
building on pandoc
and on the human side
building on over a
decade of experience
developing, maintaining
and tweaking
these packages as
well as community
feedback and the community, and
the extension package is
developed by the community.
And such a unification
process presents a really nice
opportunity to
identify and address
gaps in functionality
and inefficiencies
in user experience.
And developing Quarto
has been no different.
So some highlights
of these improvements
that are near and
dear to my heart
are a consistent implementation
of attractive and handy
features across outputs: tabsets,
code-folding, syntax
highlighting.
Imagine these things
just working out
of the box regardless of
what you're producing.
Also more accessible
defaults as well
as better support for
creating accessible documents
guardrails that are particularly
helpful for new learners,
things like YAML completion
and informative syntax errors.
And perhaps excitingly,
for those of you
who are not coming to this
from the R Markdown ecosystem,
support for other
languages like Python, Julia
observable via
the Jupyter engine
for executable code chunks.
So by now I am
assuming you've already
started playing with
Quarto or you're just
waiting for me to do that.
So let's dive in and take a look
at what all the Quarto fuss is about.
So here I have something that
might look familiar: an
R Markdown document.
Let's try this one more time.
An R Markdown document
that has some YAML on top,
some text and some code.
Many of you have
seen this before.
Let's knit this document.
It's a very, very
simple analysis
using the
palmerpenguins data set
that has a nice
visualization at the bottom.
So what I'm going to
do first is switch over
to the visual editor.
I personally really like
writing in the visual editor.
It allows you to do things
like can bold things
and italicize things without
having to write Markdown code.
And Julia will do a demo of the
visual editor a bit more later.
But I'd like to show
that whether you're
using the visual or the source
editor with R Markdown,
the output looks
exactly the same.
So it's just about your
personal preference
about authoring
on the input side.
But what we're going to do next
is actually change things up.
Let's close that file.
And what I'm going
to do is just rename
that RMD to be a QMD
not touch anything else.
The little logo
changes, I open it up.
And what I have is a render
button instead of a knit button
and I can see that the
document just works.
So Quarto is able to render
R Markdown documents.
The output looks a little bit
different, slightly different
styling, but we haven't
changed anything else.
We're going to
change the YAML now
to include the
format field instead
of output, which is how we
define different format types.
I'm going to click
on render and save
so that I don't
have to click Render
every time I make changes.
So again, this is basically
our starting place with Quarto.
I can do different output
formats, so let's create a PDF.
One of the things I really like
about creating PDFs with Quarto
as a person who doesn't
like creating PDFs
is that the PDF appears
in the viewer as opposed
to in a pop up window.
But let's go back to
HTML and take a look
at some of these chunk options.
So with Quarto, we're
using the hash pipe
for defining our
chunk options, which
I think helps with
readability a lot
and we have really nice
completion for YAML.
So if I can't
figure out what was
that chunk option for
hiding my chunks oh echo,
how would I define my the
values, true or false?
I can rely on the YAML
completion to do that.
And now on the output, we
don't have that code chunk
appearing anymore.
I can also set global chunks.
And maybe like me, this is one
of your most Googled things.
How do I set global
chunks and knitr?
I can actually just do
that now in the YAML
through the execute
field so I can turn off
the display of code chunks
for the entire document very
explicitly at the top.
And now they're all gone.
Well, we've been working with
an HTML document which is going
to produce web ready output.
Let's take a look
at one more thing.
One of the reasons why I
like these chunk options
as hash pipes is when you have
really long chunk options, say,
if I want to insert this lengthy
text for as alternative text
for the plot that
I am producing,
it stays very kind of legible.
And obviously the
alternative text
is not going to be
visible in the output.
But if I was to
inspect that element,
I can see that text is
in the HTML source code.
So that is still accessible
to screen readers.
Making these things
easier is going
to make more folks
write alternative text.
I think for the visualizations
that they're producing,
let's make a presentation.
I don't need to touch
the rest of my code.
I am just going to change
my YAML header to format,
revealjs and create a
revealjs presentation.
My title page is
basically whatever
was in the YAML of my document.
And you can see that each
of the section headers
are now new slides.
I have that really squished
plot because the revealjs tries
to help me by making my
plots take just as much space
as there is, but I can
easily insert another header,
a second level
header to just move
that content to the next slide.
And to me, being able to
do this without touching
the rest of the content is
really, really satisfying.
All right.
So let's go back to HTML.
And next, what
we're going to do is
attempt to make a website
in less than 10 minutes.
So I have a single
HTML document here.
I'm going to create
one more document.
So we're basically expanding
from a single document
to bringing multiple
documents together
in a Quarto project.
I'm going to keep this
document very simple
intentionally no
computing in there.
We're just going to put
a little bit of text.
So I've titled my
document welcome.
And maybe let's add some
plain text like "This
is the demo site for the talk".
Next, let's bring them together.
I'm going to create a YAML
file, a _quarto.yml file.
And I am going to
write YAML on the fly.
And I can do that relying
on the completion again.
So we're creating
a Quarto project.
There are various types
of Quarto projects
you can create.
The type where I'm going
to select here is website.
And then I am
going to define how
I want to lay out my website.
Let's give it a title.
I'll call it Quarto and I'm going
to create a navigation bar.
And on the left side
of the navigation bar,
I'm going to link to the
two documents I have,
the index.qmd I just
created and the
Hello.qmd that I had renamed from
that original R Markdown file.
The next thing
I'm going to do is,
I like to stay in
the RStudio IDE, but I
want my build tab to be able
to get my website going.
So I'm just going to restart
my project, my RStudio project,
and I have a build tab
that gives me the option
to render or preview a website.
Let's render the website and
see what that looks like.
And there we go.
We have a website with
multiple pages in it
that we have very
clearly written out
in this simple and
expressive YAML file.
To me, this is
incredibly encouraging. [applause]
Next what I'm going to do is I'm
going to start setting things
up for Julia.
So and also try to
be kind to myself.
I have lots of computation
and that hello.qmd
Let's assume and I don't want
this to constantly keep running
every time I update things.
So I'm going to set
the freeze feature
to true, which says only
rerun the computation when
I explicitly ask you to
do so in that document.
Otherwise, as I
change other things,
don't rerun the computation.
You can see that
when I set this,
I get this freeze folder where
the results of my computation
is stored and I can
set freeze to be
other values like automatic,
where it would only update
if you actually
touch that file, I'm
going to set it equal to
true so that let's see
if Julia can later recreate this
website in a non-R environment.
So I have a website, I have
stored my computations,
I have multiple pages.
What next?
Yeah we should be
able to publish it.
All right.
Well, we could with
one command!
quarto publish. I write quarto publish
in the terminal to
publish this to quarto.pub.
So if you do want to see
the published website,
I'm not sure why the
video is hanging,
but if you do want to see
the published website,
you could go to mine.quarto.pub/hello-demo
and the website is there, the
two pages that we created,
and we're able to do
that without setting up
things like actions to run
our code and whatnot with one
line from the terminal.
All right.
So what did we see here?
Now that you've all had a chance
to kind of see Quarto in action,
you might be wondering, how are
R Markdown in Quarto different?
Especially because we were
able to just get things
going by renaming that file.
The main difference is
that with R Markdown,
it is the R package,
R Markdown that
does the heavy
lifting of what needs
to happen to go from the
RMD file to your output.
And that's something we as R
users are very accustomed to.
You want to solve a problem,
install that packages
the package that
solves the problem
you want to solve. With Quarto
on the other hand, it's
the command-line interface,
so not an R package
but a command-line
interface, something
like Git for example,
that's actually
doing the heavy lifting
of taking your input file,
running your executable code
chunks through either knitr
or jupyter, creating
a plaintext Markdown
file that then
uses pandoc to get
to the output of your choice.
So this is technically
pretty impressive,
but I'm going to be
very honest with you,
it's not exactly what sparked
my interest about Quarto.
What did spark my
interest about Quarto
was how easy it makes it to
move between various formats.
So, as an educator, the things
that are of utmost importance
to me is that the artifacts
I create are reproducible
and that there is an
ease of transition
between various output formats.
At the risk of sounding
like a broken record,
I do actually have to
relay the same information
to my students in slides as kind
of lecture notes in a homework
assignment posted on
the course website.
So oftentimes I'm
moving the same content
around these different formats.
And over the last year
of doing this with Quarto,
I felt like I finally
found the tool that
allows me to do this easily
without futzing around
with my code and the
content part of my document.
But just changing a couple
of things in the YAML.
For example, if I want to
lesson kind of a single document
as lecture notes or something,
I can say format HTML,
I can easily change that
to revealjs without touching
anything else in my document
and I have a slide deck,
I can simply call that file in
a _quarto.yml file to create a website.
And you can see that the
all I needed to change
is just the YAML.
I didn't have to
remove slide breaks.
re-level headers.
That does save me some time.
And that time can go to
actually focus on the content
that I'm developing and that
I find extremely liberating.
But ultimately for
the kind of easily,
while easily creating
documents in multiple formats,
is nice for the sharing
story to be complete.
The tool needs to support
easily sharing things as well.
So something like
that, quarto publish command
that you can run in the
terminal and I'm sure soon
a button in the RStudio IDE.
I think that tooling
that makes it
easy to share what you do
with the world on the web
is incredibly useful.
And it's not just useful
to you, but to the world
as it facilitates open
sharing of knowledge
for learning and reuse.
I've been talking
about me and my work
so far, but I, like
many of you, don't
operate in a silo
disconnected from others.
Much of my work and much of
Julia's work is collaborative.
So over to you, Julia, for
collaborating with Quarto.
Thanks, Mine.
I have gained so much from
the open sharing and the web
first approach from
the R community,
and it has so informed
the way that I collaborate
and the way that I work.
So I work at the intersection
of actionable environmental
science, open science
and data science.
And what I absolutely love
doing is mentoring, teaching
and empowering communities.
Having learned from so
many of you, like I said,
and I wanted to pay this
forward and welcome more folks
to this experience that I've
had with the R and Mozilla
communities in particular.
So I've made this my
job through Openscapes.
Openscapes is an
approach and a movement
that I launched in 2018
and have built together
with my partner, Erin Robinson.
Our flagship activity is
mentoring research teams
and open science.
We think of open science
as a beautiful landscape
full of open source software,
data and communities
and many paths forward.
And we help people move
from the sad, lonely animals
in the foreground,
on the bottom left
and towards this
landscape, so that they
can explore this and navigate
this safely with their teams.
And our role is to welcome
folks at the trailhead
and help them establish what
that trailhead even looks like.
Who's there, who is
part of the team?
How can we think about who
can be included and start
this journey together
with limited trampling
and frustration?
So we work with professional
research groups in government,
academia and nonprofits,
and we help these teams
modernize their workflows
and shift their culture
with their teams and
within their organizations
through open source software
and open source practices.
Adyan Rios from
NOAA Fisheries
has been part of Openscapes,
and she describes in this way.
She says, as
fisheries scientists,
we know that when
we're in rough seas,
it's important to keep the
fish afloat.
It's also important to
keep the ship afloat
and to get out of
the storm, she says.
Openscapes helps
teams steer out
of the storm of email
chains with 37 versions
of the same spreadsheet
and into the calmer
waters of open science and
meaningful collaboration using
tools like R.
So I think that I
have the best job.
I get to mentor and
collaborate with teams
like Adyan's who are doing
really critical and hard work
around environment and climate.
And I get to help them do it
a little better by connecting
them to the open source
tools and community resources
that we all produce.
And it really blends working
with these teams really blends
for me the role of mentoring
and collaborating because I
learned so much along the way.
And this is definitely true
with our story with NASA.
With NASA, you probably
think about outer space,
but they collect an unbelievable
amount of data about Earth.
And researchers used
Earth data in many ways,
including how to understand
impacts of the heat
waves and the wildfires
that we're increasingly
seeing through the summers
due to climate change.
These data are freely available
from 12 different data
centers across NASA,
but researchers
have to download
these data locally
from each of these data
centers to analyze it locally.
And this puts a huge
burden on the researchers.
So now, following many
years of preparation,
these data are migrating to the
cloud through AWS and others.
And NASA's data centers will
be supporting researchers
who will be migrating
their analytical workflows
to the cloud too.
So my partner Erin had 10
years of experience working
with the NASA Earth data community,
and she brought NASA and open
scapes together in a three year
project that we lead together.
And our focus is on
developing, first and foremost,
a mentor community across
those 12 data centers.
So that they can
co-create and teach
common tutorials for
these researchers
using NASA's Earth data.
So let me just stop here and
say that this is a big project
and it is awesome, but it was
also incredibly intimidating
to me.
I do not know the
NASA community.
This is an organization I've
looked up to my whole life.
I'm not familiar with these
types of huge spatial data
that they're working with.
The type of research
questions or scientists
are asking and modeling, not to
mention cloud infrastructure,
which is a whole new era.
But an additional thing that
was particularly intimidating
to me as an R person is
that many Earth scientists
use Python and they are
developing tutorials primarily
in Jupyter Notebooks.
And my role in leading
NASA's Openscapes
was not to learn Python
from the ground up,
but I needed to be able to
collaborate and interoperate
and support Python users.
So something really
powerful, though,
is that I brought almost
a decade of experience
and confidence
using R Markdown,
and I've been able
to, you've probably
heard me talk about this
because I talk about it a lot,
I feel like it's a superpower.
And Quarto let me bring
this superpower to Python.
Quarto is emerging right
when we needed it,
and I asked JJ if we could use
Quarto for NASA's Openscapes.
It was really early
in its development
and this became a really
exciting collaboration
between the Quarto developer
team and the NASA mentors.
This was a really generous
and gracious group of people
together as we were
learning how to collaborate
together and build tutorials
and try new software,
and we were able to, through
our questions and use influence
some of the design features,
particularly the freeze feature
and how it operates
with Jupyter Notebooks.
So this is the
first Quarto site we
developed for our first
teaching event last fall.
This is where we really found
traction as a mentor community,
and we were able to make
this beautiful collection
of tutorials that
was, first of all,
helpful for our own
development as we were learning
to collaborate with each
other because we could
see which tutorials
were there already
and where the gaps were.
But it was also a very
friendly, contained place
for our learners to navigate
through these resources.
And importantly, Quarto
was also something
that we were all able
to learn together,
and that turned out to be really
important, because it turned
out I wasn't the only person
who was intimidated by all
these moving pieces on all
these new pieces of software
and how to collaborate together.
Learning Quarto together
opened the door for us
to talk more about our workflows
and develop better systems
for collaborating and really
take this to the next level.
And from all of our
investment and workflows,
we were then able
to rapidly create
additional resources for
the other teaching workshops
that we were leading
that were designed
to meet those learners where
they were and interoperate
between the materials
we developed.
So there's two things
to highlight here.
The first is that Quarto
enables collaborating
across coding languages.
This is one peak of a
way to think about this.
This is a simplified view
of one of our YAML files
where you can see we've got
multiple file types here.
These are mostly we've mostly
focused on ipynb Jupyter
Notebook files in our
primary development so far.
But as we've worked more and
more with the NASA research
community, we've discovered
that's not the right word.
We've found that there is a
substantial R community using
NASA Earth data cloud, and
it's really exciting
that the workflow
we've invested in
and have developed
together we can use
to support R users as well.
The second is that Quarto
enables contributing
from our current tools.
So some of our team,
mainly me and Erin,
used RStudio primarily
some used jupyter lab VS
code, some directly,
some edit directly
in GitHub through the editor.
And this was really
important that we were all
able to use our own tools
because with all these moving
pieces, we were
able to integrate
that workflow into the
comfort of our own tools.
So let me show you
what Quarto looks
like in Jupyter Notebooks.
So this is a Jupyter
Notebook and it's actually
running in our Jupyter Hub.
You can see we're
going to interoperate
with Quarto in the
terminal here on the right,
and we've got all the files that
Mine just created on the left.
So the first thing we'll do
is we'll say Quarto preview.
And this will open this
will provide a URL where
we can review the previewed
version of the site
that Mine has created.
So I don't have
R installed here,
but with the freeze
function I'm able to open
in this new environment.
So here is our
beautiful website.
I like to kind of
have them side by side
so I can see them refresh.
And if we want to add a Jupyter
Notebook, let's say, oh, look,
I just added one.
Great let's have a look at it.
So this is a Jupyter Notebook
I've got over here on this tab.
And this is how we
can think about Quarto.
We've got our YAML at the top
where we're going to say Hello
to Quarto penguins in Python.
We've got R Markdown
text here and we're
going to use the palmerpenguins
package in Python.
This is how we'll load
the packages and the way
you operate this in
a Jupyter Notebook
is that you execute
the code as you go.
So when I press
this play button,
this is going to
execute that code
and actually embedded
in the document.
So we'll do that again
with a plot about penguins
by clicking this button.
And now this plot is here
as part of the document.
So the workflow here is that
you execute the code as you go
and as you develop and then
you save your file as you go.
So this is the workflow
in a Jupyter Notebook.
And when we save that.
Now we can think
about adding this
to our _quarto.yml
and the way we do
that is exactly the
way that Mine did.
Before I can add a Jupyter
Notebook right here next
to these Quarto files.
And when we save
this YAML file, we're
able to peek at the terminal.
That's going to tell us
when the site refreshes.
And there is our Indeed
our Hello Quarto in Python.
You can see it's beautiful.
And it looks exactly the same
as the QMD documents in R.
So let's play around
a little bit more.
And I'll show you two
more things in Quarto.
So if we wanted to add a
figure caption to this plot,
we would use the same
hash pipe comment system
that Mine just introduced.
So I can put this
figure caption here
and again, I can
execute and save.
And this when I
refresh over here.
This will show up
in our document
and there is our header or
yes, our figure caption.
But you can see
that it's not here.
It doesn't do anything
to the Jupyter Notebook.
It's a comment in the
Jupiter ecosystem.
This it's not affecting the
Jupyter Notebook at all.
Let's add one other feature
here in the comment.
I'm sorry.
In the code chunk option.
Let's say we wanted to
display this plot in the margin
instead.
This is a style that
that's quite popular.
So I might have to make this
a little bit wider so we
can have a look.
A little bit wider.
There is our plot in the
margin from a Jupyter Notebook.
Woo! [applause]
so let's now say that
operating between formats
is really important,
particularly
when we're in collaborating.
So a workflow that's
been really powerful
is to convert Jupyter
Notebooks into Quarto documents
so that checking
them in with GitHub
can reduce merge conflicts.
So what I can do here is to
say Quarto convert and tell it
the file and it will by
default turn it into a QMD
and you can go back and
forth between these formats.
So you can see it's created
a new QMD document.
And when I open it
in the editor here,
this is now that same document
with our familiar view
in QMD form, and you can
see the Python code there.
So this has a lot of
utility and power,
and it's very important
for teaching as well.
So Mine, I'll turn it over
to you for teaching.
Thank you.
So over the last decade,
I have thoroughly
enjoyed teaching
with R Markdown.
When you get students in
the class for the first time
and you give them like a fully
functional R Markdown document
and ask them to hit
knit and they can
see their text and their
code and the output
come together before they
even learn any programming.
You can almost
hear a 'wow, that's
so cool' in the classroom.
And I've also loved that
this tool is something
you can introduce to
introductory students
on the first day of class and
that it can grow with them.
However, as students expertise
grow in statistics and also
in computing and
also their needs
grow in terms of the
different outputs they
need to produce to say,
just a single homework
document that they
can turn in as an HTML
to a well formatted journal
article or a thesis that
meets the school style.
There is a little bit
of friction that happens
and one a pleasant
surprise for me this
was a pleasant
surprise with Quarto
has been that this leveling
up has been a lot smoother.
The learning curve for
going from a single document
to a multi document project
has been a lot smoother.
So I'll tell the story
of one of my students.
So this is Holland Stam.
She's an art history
and visual media
studies student who I met when
she was taking my regression
course
just last spring.
Holland came to my class with
just one semester of intro data
science under her belt and where
she had learned R Markdown.
And in my class we
drop these students
into learning Quarto after
a brief overview of how
it's different than R Markdown.
And so she was doing her
homework assignments and stuff
as single documents
in R Markdown,
but at the same time working
on her art history thesis, which
was pretty quantitative.
So if you have ever
taken an art history class,
you might be familiar
with these two textbooks.
Gardner's 'Art Through the
Ages' and Janson's history of Art
These are foundational
Art history textbooks
that have been
around for decades
at this point with
multiple editions.
And what Holland was looking
for is representation
of different genders and
ethnicities of artists
and how much space is given
to them in these textbooks
and how this changes, if at
All of this has changed
throughout the editions.
You can see her meticulously
measuring in this picture.
This is exactly what she
did to collect her data,
actually measure the art that
is featured in the textbooks
through the editions, and
then join this information
with demographic
data on the artists
so that we could analyze and
kind of try to build a model
to see if things have
changed over the years, what
representation looks like.
On the sad side,
the representation
was exactly what you would
imagine, the lack thereof.
But on the happier
side of this story,
as she was working
on her thesis,
she realized each of my
chapters could be just
like one of my homework files.
Because ultimately, what
do we do in our homework?
Write a bit of code, get some
results out, interpret it.
And that's exactly
what she was doing.
And then with a bit
of Googling around
and a little bit
of help for me, she
was able to bring
these chapters together
with a single YAML file.
And turned it into her thesis.
Now, this wasn't
without friction, right?
This sort of leveling
up for is not easy.
However, when she realized
that she can add captions
to her figures as she creates
them in the code chunks
and that she can,
she does not have
to manually style citations,
millions of citations
she had for this thesis
project that she can just
use a visual editor to
insert these citations.
She decided I am willing to
put in the effort to do that.
So as a side story, Holland was
in my kind of research lab,
and she also worked with another
student of mine, Sara Lemus,
and they packaged up this data.
So Sara was incredibly
inspired by Holland's enthusiasm
about this project.
And Sara is a stat
student who had
been working with me
over that semester
to learn a little bit
of package development
by updating some of the
data packages I maintained.
So it was very clear to
us that the enthusiasm
between these two students, they
should come together and work
on this project together.
So if you're
interested in the data
that Holland collected and Sara
and Holland put together,
you can actually get
this package off CRAN.
Now, it's called arthistory
and has a really cute hex.
All right.
So just like Holland.
Quarto has solved a lot of
my problems as an instructor
as well, so I am going to
demo a few of those to you.
Now, first and foremost, you
can open a Quarto document
in the RStudio IDE and render it.
Now, I've shown you this before.
Why am I saying it again?
I do not have to
install anything.
Everything comes bundled.
So if you are
teaching in the RStudio IDE,
no installation required and
we can basically get going.
And I think to me, that's
incredibly liberating.
Beyond that, though, there's
really handy features.
For example, with a single YAML
field code-link set to true
I can each of the
documents that I
create can now look a little
bit like package documentation.
You may have seen where
the functions are clickable
and it takes you directly
to the documentation
for that function.
And that is incredibly helpful
for learning and teaching
because it saves me a lot of
time from adding those links.
Now on the learning side,
let's try to make a mistake
and let's see that
it's really hard.
I want to write FALSE
in capital letters.
I'm trying to make a mistake.
Quarto is constantly telling
me, don't do it, Mine,
but let's go ahead and
think that I actually
managed to do that.
And let's render this document.
The error that we
get is human readable
and it tells me
exactly what to do.
It says maybe you should try
false in small letters instead.
And this is incredibly helpful
for new learners and also
experts who might be
frustrated reading
through cryptic YAML
errors and really
kind of pushes you in the right
direction to get things going.
So that again, you can
focus on your content
and not the minutia in a way.
Now, as I said, as an
educator, a lot of slide decks
is kind of like my life.
So let's turn this into
revealjs presentation
again and let me show you
a few of the handy features
here that I use regularly.
The fact that you get a
document outline by default
is really nice.
If somebody loses their
place, everyone always asks,
can I get a PDF of the slides?
Now they can without you
having to do anything extra.
Other things that
are really handy
is being able to annotate
your slides so we
can turn on the
chalkboard feature,
and this way you can go
to something like a plot
and start outlining things.
If you like me have been an
educator through the pandemic,
I bet you spent hours
in faculty meetings.
How are we going to show
things to students on Zoom?
Well, this is one way
that we can do this.
We can also open a
chalkboard and just
start writing on it, which
is really handy when you're
teaching in a classroom where
there's a projector screen
but nothing else.
I can also turn on
multiplex, which
is the feature we're using right
now if you're following along
and it will move forward
your slides for you.
So if your students
fall asleep, they
can sort of stay with you
as you go through things.
In order to do this, you open
the speaker file and kind
of present from that and post
the nonspeaker file for them.
Another thing I'm going to do
here is to turn on the code
so that it is visible,
because when I'm teaching,
I would like to show the code to
my students and let's show one
more handy feature.
Oftentimes when you have
a big chunk of code,
like a lengthy
ggplot code, you may
want to iterate through that
highlighting things line
by line.
So with one chunk
option, you can
define which lines
you want to highlight,
and it automatically
adds animation to your
slides so that you
can step through them.
And to me, that's
really helpful because I
didn't have to add characters
to my code to do that.
Now my plot is tiny.
That's not helpful.
But again, without me having
to do extra work to move it
on the next slide, I can say
change the output location
to next slide and it will
automatically do that for me
without me referring back to an
older chunk label or something
like that.
So again, a lot of these
things, many of you
might know how to solve,
but I think the fact
that they're solved so
elegantly is quite liberating.
The last thing I'm
going to talk about
is what about the
research side of my life?
Well, let's open a new
project and let's go ahead
and write a paper.
I'm going to submit a paper
to the Journal of American
Statistical Association
with one click.
I can basically
from the terminal
use one of the templates
that are available
and there's a growing
number of templates there.
Should I trust the authors?
What do you guys think?
Should we trust the
Quarto development team?
I think I'm going
to say, yeah, OK.
And I'm going to call
this 'my awesome paper'.
This will generate
a template for me
that I can author in Quarto.
Which means I can put
my code and my text
in the same document,
which is how I generally
like to write my code.
And another nice thing
here is that if I
was to get rejected
from this journal
and wanted to submit to another
one, changing between styles
is pretty easy again without
changing your source code.
So let's go ahead
and give it a title.
My awesome paper that's
ready to be submitted
and I'll put my
name as first author
and we can render
it to a document.
And if any of you
in the audience
have used the
ASA style before,
the output should look
pretty familiar to you.
Woo! woo! [applause]
Now there's unfortunately
one drawback.
Quarto does not write
your paper for you.
But my experience with the
Quarto development team
is that when you
open issues, they're
really quick to respond.
So I don't know,
maybe by the end
of the week they'll
figure out how
to write our papers for us to.
All right.
So we've talked about
flattening the learning curve
and, you know, basically saying
that when we are leveling up
from a single document
to a multi document input
and going to various
output types,
and I said that this was
a pleasant surprise to me.
In hindsight, it should
not have been a surprise.
It's just not what I was
thinking when I first
started teaching with Quarto.
But if you think about
the features of Quarto
like consistent citation
syntax across various formats,
more intentional control over
when you should run and rerun
your computation, and a single,
minimal human readable YAML
that controls inputs, layouts
and theming everything in one
file.
All of these features contribute
to flattening that curve
for creating more
complex outputs.
But beyond just
growing and expanding
the scope of your
work with Quarto,
I think that Quarto can grow
with learners in a profound way
as well.
The fact that Quarto is
language and independent
and also authoring
tool independent
offers an opportunity for
folks to take Quarto with them
in their data science
journey, wherever
that journey might take them.
I mean, after working on this
for a year almost with Julia,
I am almost tempted to learn
Python and maybe I will.
But you know what?
Who is learning
Python are my
students, and they're
learning Python and Julia
and other languages,
mostly in their computer
science courses.
And to imagine that they could
learn R in RStudio with Quarto
in my class and then go take
a computer science class
where they're probably
living in a Jupyter Notebook
and learning Python
but still using Quarto.
That sounds like an incredibly
bright future to me.
And a bright future
includes things
we can't imagine yet as well.
So Julia will now tell us a bit
about reimagining with Quarto.
Thanks, Mine.
So we've already
seen how much Quarto
can do for teaching and
collaborating and sharing.
And now I want to
push it a bit further.
What if we could reimagine open
science as part of the climate
movement?
We know what this R community
and the open science
and open source
communities are capable of.
So what if we put that
energy towards climate?
Because we're in a
climate emergency,
we must rapidly and
radically reshape society.
We need every solution
and every solver.
This is hard and it's big.
And my hope lies is in
this community and the climate
researchers and everyone
in this movement
who feels like what they do
every single day plays a part.
So let's think about this
concretely with three user
groups in this community
of in this movement.
First, our scientists
who are working directly
in line with climate change.
This could be
fisheries scientists
who are studying where our
food sources are migrating
to as the oceans warm and
operating with managers
and stakeholders there.
They're working with really hard
problems, these really hard,
big problems.
And they can also feel
stuck on the little problems
of moving files around and
interoperating with each other.
That's really where
openscapes has been,
really bringing this
passion and this movement
that we feel in the community
to help these researchers
and help connect them there.
And I think now so many
of you that I talked to
in the open source and
R communities in this,
so the second category is open
science and R communities.
A lot of you are
feeling stuck too.
You're feeling the
pressure on climate
and feeling like changing to
more efficient light bulbs
isn't enough.
What if you aligned your daily
work as part of climate action
as well?
We want Posit to be
around in 100 years.
What is 100 years going
to look like if we
don't act now and really
put this effort together?
And the third category in
theme with the conference
is extendable
beyond these two categories.
So we really need every
solution and every solver
across all facets of geographies
and people and skill level.
And experience with technology.
So this work is really hard and
we'll return to concrete things
that we can do in a moment.
But this really does
mean slowing down a bit
in order to speed up, but
it speeds up like a flywheel.
My colleague Ileana Fenwick
is a marine ecologist
who participated in open
scapes earlier last year
and she really quickly
became a member
of the team teaching and
extending and connecting
other communities and
seeing what was possible.
And the way she describes
this is beautiful.
Because of Openscapes,
I've renewed hope
In how we can bring about
a kinder future in science.
I see a commitment in the
open science community
to bridging the gaps where
we've left members of our
own community behind,
And it inspires me.
So we're talking about a
profound culture shift that
involves real,
deliberate work on both
the tech and the human side.
And we've got the tech
side really figured out
it's where the momentum
and the potential
and what we're all doing
is amazing and phenomenal.
And we can bring that power and
energy to the human side, to we
can build inclusion
into our daily work.
So let's think about the teams
or the colleagues or the people
that you interact with, because
I think that they are probably
way more similar to the groups I
work with than we might expect.
First of all, it means
talking to colleagues,
asking them how they're doing.
Are they stuck?
What is their
workflow look like?
Where is their friction?
Who's contributing
to our workflow?
Where are the handoffs?
Maybe between reports or data?
Where are people
feeling friction?
What can we do to help?
So this means asking
all these questions,
but really, and
that's hard enough,
those open-ended questions.
Another hard part is listening.
Listening is really hard.
It takes it means that
you are not trying
to assume what they need.
You're not trying
to solutioneer
as soon as you hear
something, because oftentimes,
we don't even have language
to describe where we're stuck.
And that's part of the problem.
So it also means
then stepping up
and being braver to ask for
help and say what you need.
And really create
this culture where
what we feel in the R
community around R code
is also applicable to climate.
So this is a practice to
develop daily, to work on,
to help others with.
It's not a checklist.
It's a daily thing
that we can all do.
So here is a practical
example of this.
Gavin Fay's lab group
at UMass Dartmouth
created the Fay lab manual
together during the pandemic.
Here they so they are
quantitative fisheries
ecologists.
They work with data and code
to work on fisheries, things
that I just described
a bit earlier.
So it is uncommon for people
in the environmental field
to have data science training
in the universities right now.
So that means people coming
into this quantitative group
have varying levels of
expertise and experience.
And so they wrote this
lab manual as a way
to not only write down
their lab philosophy,
their code of conduct, how
they wanted to work together.
They talked about
where, how to name files
and also how to learn
the tools that they're
going to develop together.
So this is a living online open
document, and it's imperfect.
And it's radical in
science, where we often
wait until after the research
is done to publish something.
And that happens
years into a career
and really limits
the participation.
Folks feel they have
an agency they have.
So this is radical in
three ways or in many ways.
But let me tell
you three of them.
One is that it makes
the implicit explicit.
The team all know because
they co-created the document.
They're all on the same
page, literally Quarto page.
And to understand how
they work together,
they're able to put their values
forward and not only reduce
the amount of emails where
people are asking where things
are, but also really
put this out there
and welcome other
people to join them.
And when folks are interested
in joining this lab group,
they mention this document
as a welcoming reason.
A second thing is that
this document onboards
learners as contributors.
So first of all, there
is an onboarding process
and it's written in the site.
And so it instructs you not only
to how the lab works, but also
how you can use Quarto to fix a
typo to update a link you saw.
So you're contributing
to the lab group.
You're, you're
joining in that way
and you're contributing
to science on day one.
And that is just amazing to
have that kind of empowerment
and imagine where what
you feel like you're
going to do in science next.
So this is hugely
radical for science.
And the third most radical
thing is the investment
they put into psychological
safety and growth mindsets
in their group.
Psychological safety
is the idea that it's
a shared understanding
within a team,
that team is safe for
interpersonal risk taking.
That means that people feel
comfortable to ask a question
if they don't something
that they feel like they
can give and receive feedback.
So this is really important,
along with a growth mindset
where everyone can
learn from everyone.
This is the power of yet:
I don't know this yet.
I can't do
this yet, but I can.
And that kind of
mindset and learning
across the hierarchy of science,
across expertise and skills,
thinking that we all have
something to contribute
is really important.
So reimagining within
this one lab group then
can scale that this
slowing down can then
have rapid effects with that
speeding up and amplifying.
So really quickly after this,
we forked the Fay labs idea
and wrote our own Quarto
approach guide for Openscapes.
This is how we work together and
onboard ourselves and onboard
others to the team
and also other groups
are able to use it to. The
California Water Boards are
leading their first Openscapes
sessions this summer
and at NOAA fisheries they
saw what NASA was doing
and forked that
idea with Quarto.
So they are using
Quarto for a place
to build community across their
NOAA science centers for Open
Science and to connect
and to empower and enable
these early adopters
within each of these silos.
So these are examples of
Quarto for culture change
and it's amazing.
We can do this with
the same tooling
that we're using for our
reproducible research
at the same time.
These documents from
where they are now
don't have any code in them.
They're there.
And Quarto is a
really friendly place
for folks to contribute no
matter where their comfort
level is with code.
And that's really important.
We've already seen
features of Quarto
that are really friendly.
And with guardrails to help
new learners contribute.
And another way for this,
for newcomers to contribute
is in the visual
editor and I'm
going to do one final demo
here about the visual editor.
But I also want to emphasize
that while I'm well,
we're going to look at it
through the lens of a new user.
This is a really powerful
tool for experienced users.
And so as part of this
mindset of helping
welcome other people,
as I walk through this,
maybe consider how you
might use this approach
to welcome one of
your colleagues
who might be less, less sure
about this kind of tech.
So here we are in the IDE and
I've opened Mine's home page,
her home page Quarto
document and I'm immediately
going to go to the visual
editor like she showed before.
So I can type in Quarto
in the visual editor
and then I can use the menu bars
up here as I would in a Google
Doc to make a header.
And as I type I can
also highlight words
and make them italic.
I can use keyboard
shortcuts like command
I to turn off the italics.
And this is a way that I can
comfortably write my text.
I can also paste formatted text.
This is a way we use.
Quarto quite often is
by interoperating
between other documents
that we're using,
and it's amazing that it
saves that formatting.
If we want to add an image.
We can use the
Insert feature here
and see all of these
different things
that we'd be able to insert.
Right now we'll insert
an image and we could
type this or browse a file.
I'll speed this up for
the purpose of our demo.
In a moment we can
set center, but I'm
going to paste the caption and
the Alt text for us right now.
And then we can press OK.
And this is now in
the visual editor.
We can see it, we can
understand how it interoperates
with our document and we
can also resize it there
on the fly, which is awesome.
If we're interested
in the source code,
let's have a look at it.
And you can see down here on
line 15 is where the image is
and that where the
cursor is, we've
got the width and the
figure line center.
That's what we had
done with our mouse,
but that's now in
Quarto for us.
So back in the visual editor.
Let's save this and click
that render on Save button
that will then let us see
this live rendered output
alongside the visual editor.
So I love that render
on Save button.
When I don't have a lot
of heavy computation
so that I can every
time I save, I
get to see exactly how it looks.
Beautiful over here.
OK we can fix this typo with
those nice red squiggles lines
and let's add a citation.
Let's add a citation
for the tidyverse.
We can do this with a
command a or sorry, @ symbol.
And pull up my Zotero library.
That's all that it's
found on my computer.
I can type.
Whew sorry.
I've got.
Well, I can type either
Wickham or tidy or I'm sure
many other things.
When I add when I save
again, it's there already
in the document and I've got
the references down here.
This is amazing.
A second way you can do it is
to use the forward slash and click citation.
And then you're able to actually
even paste a DOI on the fly,
and it will find it for you.
Yes! You can see
when I save this,
it's in a different
style, which is great
that you have that
kind of control
right here from the browser.
Or from the visual editor.
I'm sorry.
I have a few more
features to show here,
but I'm thinking in
the interest of time,
we'll let you watch this
online by yourself later.
So I want to bring this
back as we close our keynote
and just say again that
we are all part of this.
We've been talking
about what Quarto enables
throughout this
talk, but this is
about what we are able to
reimagine at all levels.
We can all play our part to
do this in our daily work
and with our teams
and scale and beyond.
So we invite you to reimagine
with us because we cannot we
must not go it alone.
So if you would like to pick
up your Quarto journey to share,
collaborate, teach or
reimagine where we left off,
go to this link for
our slides and you're
going to see that we have
a few more slides for you
with resources to learn.
Quarto and also
references to some of the
works that we've cited.
And there's a
Quarto session later
on this afternoon at
320 and the Quarto and R
Markdown teams will
be at the open source
lounge between 12 and 3 today.
Thank you so much for
joining us this morning.